en américa latina sólo méxico chile y
costa rica han comenzado a vacunar a sus
ciudadanos contra el kobe 19 méxico
continúa su programa enfocándose en
médicos enfermeros y soldados el país
recibió un segundo cargamento de 42 mil
900 dosis de las farmacéuticas pfizer y
bayonne tec y más de 34 mil se
destinarán la ciudad de mexico la más
golpeada por el virus es muy importante
dado que tenemos que proteger a los que
nos protegen y entonces estas personas
sobre todo los de primera línea están
muy en contacto con personas enfermas
entonces si ellos se enferman también
suceden dos cosas una pues pueden
transmitir la enfermedad
y la otra que no solo a los pacientes o
usuarios sino que a sus familias y la
otra tiene que ver con que ellos podrían
dejar de ir a trabajar tendríamos una
disminución del sistema de salud
argentina por su parte empezará la
inoculación el martes tras haber
recibido el primer lote de 300.000 dosis
de la vacuna rusa sputnik el presidente
alberto fernández oficioso ayuda a otros
países de la región para garantizar la
adquisición del antídoto
hablé con el canciller uruguayo mi amigo
pancho gustillo y hablé con el
presidente de bolivia luis arce les dije
que en lo que yo pudiera ayudar contaban
conmigo me puse a disposición para
ayudarlos y generar los contactos
necesarios para ayudarlos a tener la
vacuna en otras naciones
latinoamericanas como colombia y ecuador
esperan que las primeras dosis de la
vacuna the fighter iv by antec lleguen a
sus territorios en enero mientras que en
brasil el presidente ya ir bolsonaro un
escéptico de la vacunación dice que no
se siente presionado para inocular su
población